mais d'abord cette maladie qui frappe
tous les ministres la téléphonie tu leur
smartphone sécurisé et greffé à leurs
mains dans la tente d'un coup de fil de
l'elysée mais malgré ou par quoi parfois
à cause de leur bilan ils ne seront pas
tous présents dans le nouveau
gouvernement c'est cécile siksou qui
évalue ce bilan qui du gouvernement
castex restera dans l'équipe d'elisabeth
bornes parmi les ex ministres certains
ne souhaitent pas faire partie du
casting comme le ministre des transports
jean baptiste djebbari qui part
travailler dans le privé ou encore le
secrétaire d'état à l'emploi adrien
taquet il veut consacrer plus de temps à
ses proches d'autres n'ont pas exprimé
ce même désir mais ne devrait pas être
reconduit comme eric dupond-moretti l'ex
garde des sceaux rêve de rester place
vendôme mais sa mise en examen et ses
mauvais rapports avec les magistrats
pourraient l'obliger à faire ses cartons
autre poids lourd sur la sellette jean
michel blanc guerre bien affaibli par la
crise qu vide il pourrait quitter
l'éducation nationale après cinq ans
pour l'un comme pour l'autre il ya
aujourd'hui des relations qui sont assez
tendus avec leurs administrations
respectives donc cette situation ces
situations sont que la ministre en
tension avec son temps avec son
administration peut être vu comme un
ministre moins efficace pour ce qu'elle
jean-michel lancker par ailleurs avoue à
demi ce qui est là depuis 2017 et donc
la nécessité ou en tout cas la volonté
d'incarner une forme de renouvellement
plaiderait plutôt pour une évolution du
ministère de l'éducation nationale sur
les quarante ministres certains devrait
tout de même rester dans l'exécutif
comme bruno le maire ou gérald darmanin
deux poids lourds qui sortent renforcés
du premier quinquennat ils ont réussi à
incarner certaines politiques publiques
pour gérald darmanin l'ordre et la
sécurité après un ministère l'intérieur
qui était difficilement qu'on paie on se
souvient du départ de gérard collomb se
souvient des difficultés qui ont été
celles de christophe castaner et de
l'autre côté un bruno le maire qui sort
plutôt renforcé de la crise qu vide avec
une action économique qui intègre oslo
plutôt saluée par l'opinion à quelques
semaines des législatives
garder ses deux ministres pourraient
aussi être une caution pour l'électorat
de centre droit alors que le
gouvernement esquisse une inflexion à
gauche
et pour débattre notamment autour de
cette attente de la liste des ministres
du 1er gouvernement d'elisabeth borne
d'accueil joséphine staron bonsoir et
bienvenue vous êtes docteur en
philosophie directrice des études et des
relations internationales du cercle de
réflexion sinopia hauteur de l'europe la
solidarité contre le naufrage justement
publié aux éditions sinopia jean
garrigues bonsoir il sous l'eau rien
priant du comité d'histoire
parlementaire votre livre la tentation
du sauveur histoire d'une passion
française est lui publié aux éditions
payot matthieu croissandeau
éditorialiste politique et soit à mes
côtés et on attend d'une minute à
l'autre yves derai qui a peut-être faire
une entrée à vue ils pleuraient
bienvenus
heureusement et ça s'appelle ça
s'appelle une entrée théâtrale ça on est
très heureux si on est très heureux de
vous accueillir vous êtes rédacteur en
chef de forbes france bienvenue à vous
on commence évidemment par la formation
de ce nouveau gouvernement avant de
s'amuser au jeu des hypothèses joséphine
staron on va rappeler une règle non
écrite de la vème république c'est à
dire que cette liste elle peut changer
jusqu'au tout dernier moment oui et on
l'a vu également avec la nomination du
premier ministre ça a pu probablement
changer jusqu'au dernier moment donc les
des surprises peuvent arriver en
revanche en faisant le choix de
elisabeth bornes emmanuel macron ne crée
pas particulièrement de surprise il fait
le choix de la continuité on a un profil
qui ressemble peu ou prou à celui de
l'ancien premier ministre jean castex
qu'on appelle technocrates un peu
politique puisque nos élus pour l is a
big bang qui va faire sa première
tentative d'élection aux législatives
dans un mois donc voilà sont des profils
assez similaire qui
qui ne soulève pas d'enthousiasmé
particulier quelques critiques c'est
normal du côté de l'opposition notamment
à gauche donc ça veut dire qu'il va
falloir surprendre par au moins une
partie de ce gouvernement sans dans sa
campagne annuelle macron a quand même
promis du changement il a promis du
renouveau déjà en 2010 est on
on promettait le renouveau démocratique
et là en 2022 notamment dans
l'entre-deux tours il a promis des
changements il a promis notamment de
regarder du côté de la société civile
donc cette formation du nouveau
gouvernement
on attend comme on l'a vu dans le
reportage une reconduite de certains
ministres charismatique et aussi des
nouvelles têtes des nouveaux inscrits
pour l'instant on n'a pas beaucoup
d'informations évidemment jean garrigues
alors il faut se préparer à emmanuel
macron peut prendre son temps c'est
absolument pas sûr qu'on ait la liste
demain en principe en général ça prend
un ou deux jours pour avoir le
l'ossature du gouvernement ensuite on
peut attendre un petit peu pour les pour
les secrétaires d'état et que c'est vrai
que connaissant emmanuel macron qui veut
vraiment rester le maître des horloges
qui a fait traîner tant qu'il a pu avant
de choisir son sassa première ministre
pour des raisons politiques qui
s'explique par là l'écart qui existe
entre le second tour de la
présidentielle et les élections
législatives s'étaient plus longue
d'habitude c'était plus longue ou
stratégiquement ça valait le coup
d'attendre
ça ça lui a semblé valait le coup la loi
le couple plus passent tellement sûre
que les français ils soient très
sensible ni d'ailleurs que les français
soient très pressé de connaître dans
l'immédiat les noms de leurs futurs
ministres mais ça c'est finalement
quelque chose de négatif parce que ça
montre que au fond il n'y a pas une
attente très forte autour de ceux de ce
gouvernement en tout cas ce qui est sûr
c'est que c'est que particulièrement
dans les circonstances actuelles ce sera
emmanuel macron qui l'a véritablement
choisir soigneusement un ses ministres
yves derai il va falloir servir aussi
toutes les grandes familles d'ensemble
et notamment le parti horizon d'edouard
philippe c'est ça fait partie des
équilibres à trouver même au delà du
parti horizon il va falloir
les équipes de gauche droite parce que
là l'acte fondateur des bêtes du
maquereau nisme c'est le en même temps
et il ne va sans doute pas sûrement pas
y renoncer et cette fois ci il va encore
falloir qui est dans ce gouvernement la
parité hommes femmes bien sûr on pense
souvent aussi à des questions
géographique pour bien couvrir le
territoire mais avec un milieu macron il
ya aussi l'idée d'un équilibre gauche
droite qu'il faut respecter juste un mot
sur ce qui est dédié aux tout débuts moi
je partage pas tout à fait l'avis
de madame sur sur la non surprise
isabelle borne et élisabeth bourgois je
me souviens que quand même crainte son
nom est sorti pour la première fois les
gens retomber un peu de l'armoire quand
même on se demandait quand même comment
il avait pu avoir cette drôle d'idée de
nommer isabelle borne qui est une femme
quand même assez strictes assez austère
ce n'est pas le glamour en politique
peut-on si vous me permettez
l'expression d'amour au sens évidemment
figurer pas au sens propre en gros
c'était on parle quand même de christine
lagarde à ce moment là qu'on a abandonné
pour être premier ministre et là c'est
vrai que ça avait un autre un autre
cachet est une personnalité beaucoup
plus forte plus charismatique avec un
poids politique et tout mais comme c'est
le premier nom qui était sorti et que
finalement on est revenu exactement
un pressentiment que ce n'est plus une
surprise parce que c'est sorti c'était
le premier nombre qu'on a eu d'autres et
c'est vrai qu'on a pensé qu' on irait
vers d audrey azoulay ou des catherine
vautrin les choses beaucoup plus
étonnant puis surprenante mais elisabeth
bornes c'est quand même un choix assez
étonnant une certes une femme de gauche
mais quand même modérément de gauche
mais dont on dit quand même que sur les
questions sociales elle est assez ferme
or il ya des réformes difficiles que le
gouvernement doit faire passer et on
s'attend à une rentrée sociale difficile
et les événements ne semble pas être
disons la prémisse de l'apaisement on
suivra ça mathieu pour vous le principal
défilé avec band c'est finalement de
faire sa mue ça a l'air de passer le
ministre techno on l'a dit à première
ministre politique oui alors ça
commencera bien sûr par la composition
de son gouvernement on aurait parlé
parité renouvellement équilibre des
sensibilités c'est pas forcément les
équations les plus complexes à résoudre
passé aussi la nature du profit des
ministres et vous en avez dit un mot à
propos de la société civile le problème
c'est que le principe d'un gouvernement
d'experts a montré ses limites en
période de gros temps en a déjà eu ça
quand même en 2017 c'était des gens
issus de la société civile
or le gros temps nous y sommes justement
et puis une première vague à surmonter
qui va être évidemment les législatives
qui se profilent autant d'arguments qui
plaident à mes yeux quand même pour un
gouvernement un peu plus politique parce
que les circonstances au delà de ces
législatives nécessite quand même des
profils plus politique hors politique
elisabeth bande il vient de le rappeler
ne l'est pas du tout enfin l'ecc à
moitié elle commence à l'être c'était
une ancienne conseillère de londres
alors les travailleuses fine
connaisseuse des dossiers c'est une
réformatrice courageuses et efficaces ou
redoutable selon le point de vue que
l'on adopte mais n'a pour l'instant ni
la légitimité d'un ancrage local ni d'un
passé militant en gros il manque à cette
surdiplômés à la fois la culture du
terrain et l'école du vice c'est
vraiment nécessaire oui d'abord pour
parvenir à gérer son gouvernement et sa
majorité alors en théorie bien sûr tout
le monde devrait avoir le doigt sur la
couture du pantalon mais en vérité en
pratique tout le monde d'avoir les yeux
rivés sur l'horizon alors pas sans
mauvais jeu de mot au sens kantien
forcément le mouvement d'edouard
philippe mais on sait bien que cette
majorité elle va être fait ni dans cinq
ans puisque emmanuel macron ne pourra
pas se représenter ce qui va susciter de
gros appétit en gérer une équipe humaine
faite d'ambition dans un contexte pareil
quand vous n'avez ni capteur de terrain
ni relais assemblée ni troupes en enrobé
c'est compliqué mais la nouvelle
première ministre va aussi devoir avoir
besoin d'une session de rattrapage
expression politique j'allais dire pour
résister aux assauts qu'elle va subir et
qu'elle accueille déjà commencé à subir
de la part de l'opposition qui est
chauffée à blanc par sa chance c'est
qu'elle est aujourd'hui difficilement
classable puisque la gauche insoumis
écologistes en tête l'accusent d'être
une femme de droite et puis la droite
par la voix d'eric ciotti ou de
guillaume pelletier dénonce en elle une
première liste de gauche ce qui devrait
lui laisser encore peut-être un peu le
temps de souffler et législatives pour
souffler fort du temps c'est dans moins
d'un mois oui alors c'est vrai que ça
fait un peu juste lancé à la fois des
premiers chantiers ou faire connaître
les premiers arbitrages mais c'est
suffisant en tout cas pour annoncer un
cap et de ce point de vue son discours
d'autres soirs relevait plus de la
convention que enfin des conventions que
que de l'intention que dieu que du capa
même s'il a commencé à lever le voile
sur deux trois choses l'écologie ou le
foie les plus forts plus vite ou la
méthode avec le dialogue qui est la
seule bonne méthode selon elle pour
pouvoir avancer dans les dossiers
compliqués mais tout ça ça fait court
d'où vraiment la nécessité d'avoir un
gouvernement qui parle parce que le
geste politique ça sera d'abord ceux de
la formation de ce gouvernement on verra
si ça permettra d'emporter l'adhésion
alors des siens d'abord et puis des
français ensuite oui merci mathieu je
voudrais qu'on se penche un peu sur l'
équilibre de ce nouveau
nous nous duo exécutif jean garrigues
parce que c'est elle doit aussi se créer
un espace d'une certaine façon elisabeth
bande si on se souvient bien edouard
philippe l'avait un peu créé dès le
départ en ne cédant pas sur le choix de
son directeur de cabinet à matignon là
c'est plutôt l'inversé qui s'est produit
si j'ai bien compris oui et puis
regardez le tweet qui a été avant tout
de suite envoyé par emmanuel macron dans
lequel au fond il l'indiquait ce que
seraient les grandes lignes de la
politique menée par il avait 16 ans et
j'avais presque l'impression qu'il donne
et les ministres d'état qui allaient
composer le gouvernement on sent bien il
faut il faut se dire les choses on sent
bien qu'on va avoir la faire un coup
tout avec un premier ministre plus
collaborateurs que véritablement tête
politique figure politique on sort ça
ressemble plus à ce qu'était le rôle de
jean castex qu'à celui d'edouard
philippe encore faut-il préciser qu'au
départ edouard feeling on n'avait pas
véritablement de lui non plus de
l'existence politique mais jean castex
qu'il avait marqué un espace aussi en
instaurant de nouveaux seins un déjeuner
séverine de madère en tête à tête ce
sont les directeurs de cabinet avec le
prion at il dit on va attendre un geste
quotidien veut véritablement existé le
problème c'est que le premier la
première phase pour exister ça va être
la préparation des élections
législatives parce qu'a priori elle est
le chef de la majorité parlementaire à
venir sauf que elle n'a pas cette
expérience et qu'elle a face à elle des
poids lourds de
d'ensemble c'est à dire de renaissance
que tu sais pas comme christophe
castaner ou à richard ferrand de dorison
ezzouar philippe et du modem françois
bayrou et donc on peut penser que pour
exister dans cet espace politique avec
ses poids lourds là ça va être plutôt
compliqué joséphine star on sait cette
idée de créer son espace politique pour
pour le premier ministre ou la première
ministre s'est aussi
et au passage au quinquennat enfin
salaires liste l'espace vital du premier
min c'est quand même un peu réduit bien
évidemment avec le passage au
quinquennat et donc la concomitance des
élections présidentielle et législatives
il est beaucoup plus difficile pour le
premier ministre le chef de gouvernement
de trouver une place une place à part
entière et de ne pas être effectivement
ce qu'on reproche depuis quelques années
un simple collaborateur alors après ça
dépend beaucoup de la personnalité et du
président et de son premier ministre
donc c'est comme on l'a dit à eux de
faire lors lors leurs preuves mais en ce
qui concerne elisabeth bornes elle un
premier passage une première étape qui
va qui va donner le lin de la suite
c'est déjà les élections législatives
parce qu'elle est elle même candidate
elle n'était pas forcément obligé de se
présenter aux élections législatives
dans quel point un risque elle prend le
risque de perdre même si pour l'instant
le sortant est un
en marche donc ya peu de risques elle
prend un risque si elle perd et bien
elle devra démissionner donc là elle
recherche une légitimité populaire
qu'elle n'a pas qu'elle n'a pas encore
une assise auprès de la société civile
auprès des citoyens pour acquérir une
légitimité qui par la suite pourrait lui
servir pour exister davantage dans ce
gouvernement moi je fais le pari que
peut nous surprendre sur sa capacité
justement à se créer un espace d'abord
dans le trio et puis ensuite un espace
politique yves derai oui tout à fait
tout à fait parce que c'est vrai qu'elle
n'a pas de poids politique et jamais de
bornes tout comme ses prédécesseurs
parce qu'on voit bien que macron ne
prend pas des premiers ministres qui ont
un poids politique et qui pourrait faire
un bras de fer avec eux dans la
formation du gouvernement qui ont des
amis qui veulent me lasser et ses îles
d'or philippe jean castex ou elisabeth
board ils doivent tous leur poste de
premier ministre à emmanuel macron car
c'est lui qui a décidé dénommé rien
imposer de les nommer mais en revanche
elle a un sens politique et je vais vous
raconter si vous me permettez une petite
taille dont j'ai été moi même un peu le
témoin mais d'une certaine manière le
protagoniste et que j'ai fait une
interview d'elisabeth bornes dans le
dernier numéro de forbes qui précède le
premier tour de la présidentielle mais
pas à ma demande à sa demande j'ai été
contacté dans une interview
pour les pages femme de force et
notamment parce qu'elle voulait parler
de parité est évidemment pas quand on
parle de parité j'ai accepté j'ai fait
l'interview et je vais parler de la
parité en politique oui moi je te dis
que ba auvergnats pas vraiment parité
elle m'a dit mais il serait judicieux
qu'à matignon emmanuel macron c'est dans
l'interview qu'on a pu oublier qu'on a
les republier là est bien un homme une
femme parce que ça fait quand même
longtemps qu'ils appellent une femme à
matignon j'ai dis mince on fait tout ça
pour ce à quoi elle avec la même envie
de faire passer un message dans un
magazine comme chose qu'un magazine ou
ou parlons lui par les décideurs et donc
ça manque quand même un sens politique
une volonté une énergie quand même
particulière et puis mathieu en tant que
ministre est-ce qu'elle a déjà eu la
capacité de dire non à emmanuel macron
oui ce que je veux dire dans section peu
compliqué quand on est ministre
le souvenir je pose la question s'est
ouvert une réputation de ministre qui
faisait avancer les dossiers qu'on lui
confiait y compris dans des
circonstances difficiles on se souvient
de la réforme du statut de la sncf qui a
été compliquée avec cette eau des rêves
perdus qu'il y aurait quand même très
très longtemps où elle a tenu bon ça a
été plus plus transparents au ministère
de la transition écologique parce
qu'elle n'y est pas resté très longtemps
et au ministère du travail elle a mis
l'accent quant même sur sur les jeunes
alors il ya des choses qui avait été
denrées qui était dans les tuyaux
qu'avait lancée al
pénicaud mai mais il ya un dispositif un
jeu dissolution
l'apprentissage
il y avait eu des débats pour savoir si
on faisait ou non le rsa jeunes il y
avait du débat pour savoir s'il fallait
ou non faire la réforme des retraites
avant avant le les élections mais je
n'ai pas le souvenir d'opposition
franche et et frontale avec le présent
de la public entre nous j'ai pas le
souvenir du studio assez frontal et de
la république doit perdre un autre
membre du gouvernement peut-être que
quand un chalmé est prêt en coulisses il
va pouvoir nous rejoindre bonsoir
quentin bienvenus
on va parler des ministres et
secrétaires d'état qui sont nombreux à
se présenter aux élections législatives
et notamment on en a parlé la première
d'entre eux exactement notre nouvelle
première ministre il est borgne qui sera
candidate dans le calvados alors c'est
effectivement la première fois qu'elle
brigue un mandat électif vous l'avez dit
elle a choisi cette circonscription
thomas car ses racines familiales ils
sont implantés sa mère est née à livarot
dans le pays d'auge elle dispose de
bonnes chances de gagner mais alors que
se passera-t-il si elle perd la
tradition veut que le premier ministre
candidat perdant législatives et bien
renonce à diriger le gouvernement le
délégué général dans marche stanislas
guérini a botté en touche ce matin sur
france info on écoute crois qu'elle n'a
pas hésité 3 secondes et je préfère
avoir une première ministre qui va aux
élections qui se soumet aux suffrages
des français que d'avoir quelqu'un qui
nie élisez moi premier ministre à une
élection où il n'est même pas quand mais
du coup la réforme la règle n'est pas
encore fixée pour elisabeth bornes comme
pour les autres ministres on sait pas
encore ce qui se passera ce merde ya
jamais eu de règles et une règle tri66
et c'est là dessus moi je crois à la
légitimité il n'y a pas de plus belle
façon il n'ya pas plus belle façon que
d'aller au fond la conquérir qu en se
soumettant aux suffrages des français
voilà pour ce qui est du reste du
gouvernement actuel est bien
effectivement ils sont nombreux à être
candidats aux élections législatives
soit 42 membres du gouvernement castex
on a compté 22 candidats aux élections
législatives 15 qui était déjà député
avant de rentrer au gouvernement élu en
2010 7 6 qui se lance vraiment pour la
première fois regardez on a pris
quelques exemples par exemple donc on a
il avait deux bornes n'a compris
l'europe les trajets ce qui sera d'état
aux retraites candidat dans le nord où
était déjà élu brigitte bourguignon et
que qui s'occupait de l'autonomie au
gouvernement elle est candidate dans le
pas-de-calais barbara pompili dans la
somme gérald darmanin dans la
circonscription qui contient tourcoing
son fief alors il est élu dans sa
circonscription il a été élu député
entre 2012 et 2016
dixième du nord et donc le ministre de
l'intérieur a tenu une conférence de
presse c'était le 5 mai dernier on va
voir quelques images aux côtés du député
sortant vincent ledoux qui devient son
suppléant et qui siègera à l'assemblée
nationale si gérald darmanin est élu il
devait rentrer dans le prochain
gouvernement de lisbonne il a expliqué
que se présenter servais bien à peser
politiquement l'écoutent
et il me semble que c'est en se
présentant suffrages des électeurs en se
mettant en danger ils ont tout à fait le
droit de ne pas choisir évidemment ma
candidature que on à l'ap le poids
politique ensuite pour porter leurs
aspirations continue la liste des
ministres candidats sur les 22 1 qui
vise un mandat à l'assemblée nationale
on voit jean michel blanquer air dans le
loiret olivier vers en isère gabriela
talent dans les hauts-de-seine amélie de
montchalin en essonne ou encore isabelle
moreno pour les français de l'étranger
la campagne officielle s'ouvre lundi ils
ne pourront plus prendre la parole en
tant que ministre s'ils sont dans le
prochain gouvernement car une période de
réserve s'ouvre alors donc lundi
jusqu'au 19 juin merci quentin pour
toutes ces informations jean garrigues
sur effectivement il disait aborde cette
cette candidature dans le calvados où on
quant à parler de règles non écrites on
a tous en tête le souvenir d'alain juppé
qui était numéro deux ministres d'état
dans le gouvernement de
nicolas sarkozy et qui s'est fracassé
sur le mur des législatives c'est une
question de légitimité je crois qu'à
raison il faut souligner la de là dessus
même si la caractéristique de la vème
république et de découpe les aider de
mettre une incompatibilité entre
exercices de ministres et de députés il
n'en reste pas moins que la légitimité
elle vient de le de l'élection et c'est
bien de le rappeler je pense qu'il le
souligne aussi beaucoup par antagonisme
avec ce qui a été décidé par celui qui
s'est décrit comme futur premier
ministre luc mélenchon s'en passer par
pas par l'élection mais c'est vrai que
ça fait partie de la légitimité il y
aura aussi un rendez-vous si tenté que
ces élections soient réussies il y aura
aussi un rendez vous d'un premier test
aussi pour elisabeth bande qui sera la
déclaration de politique générale ça ce
sera un moment quand même très important
parce que pour l'instant on peut douter
de ses capacités d'orateur on ne connaît
pas en tout cas elle ne n'apparaît pas
comme une grande femme de tribunes on se
souvient que ça s'était très mal passé
pour edith cresson mais ça s'est très
mal passé pour beaucoup d'autres premier
ministre en tout cas ça c'est toujours
une étape et et la presse l'opinion
évalue aussi les les capacités de femmes
politiques d'hommes politiques à travers
cette déclaration de politique générale
mac joséphine star on sait on peut
parler d'une forme de courage elle prend
un s qu'elle prend vraiment un risque il
avait de bordeaux est ce que c'est une
circonscription plutôt facile le risque
est mesuré étant donné que le député
sortant qui ne se représente pas et est
déjà un député de la majorité donc il y
a de fortes chances qu'elle puisse
remporter ce scrutin mais en revanche
elle n'y va pas comme simple candidate à
la députation ali vacances en tant que
premier ministre et donc les français
pourraient aussi être tentés de voter
contre elle non pas en tant que député
mais en tant que premier ministre donc
le risque il est quand même réel il y à
un danger gérald darmanin l'a rappelé il
ya toujours un danger lorsqu'on presse
présente dans une élection heureusement
c'est la garantie du bon fonctionnement
démocratique et s'y plier et bien ça
montre quand même une forme de courage
alors est ce que on le lui a demandé
est-ce qu'elle l'a voulu dans tous les
cas le fait est que le 19 juin on verra
si elle peut conserver sa fonction
premier ministre juste emmanuel macron
il a fait plus de 30%
conception que c'est un danger quand
même limité on est on est on est
d'accord on l'avait on l'avait signalé
dans cette émission et yves derai ya un
autre chapitre que je vais ouvrir sur la
composition de ce nouveau gouvernement
du premier gouvernement bornes c'est la
planification écologique la on attend
quand même et ce sera un ce seront deux
deux ministres
importantissime d'une certaine façon
kiki peut-il emmanuel macron et elles
elisabeth nord qui peuvent-ils aller
chercher alors une des personnalités que
le gist non à cinéma qu'il ya des noms
qui sont cités 1 res calque enfant
pourrait pourquoi pas rejoindre ce
gouvernement ancien d'europe écologie
désert ancien directeur du wwf fois donc
c'est une figure de l'écologie en france
après tout barbara pompe il il a pas
l'air d'être extrêmement farouche en
termes de promotion ne pose donc elle
pourrait pourquoi pas accepter aussi
d'être d'être nommé
et il pourrait y avoir aussi des
surprises avec des personnalités là pour
le coup de la société civile chance mais
c'est par exemple la négociatrice de
copains terre directrice la fondation
européenne pour le climat lens mais je
crois quand même souvent été cité comme
minisère de mai puis quelques années
mais bon mais je crois pas que là en
l'occurrence sur ce poste là cette
fois-ci emmanuel macron aura besoin d'un
gadget ou d'une personnalité un peu
ronflant parce que la nouveauté c'est
quand même que le premier ministre
l'après ministre va elle même chapeauté
le domaine de l'écologie donc que quand
il fallait auparavant le ministre de
l'ecologie avait plaidé ces arbitrages
et se retrouver face aux mines et de
l'industrie face aux mines et des
transports souvent par des arbitrages
parce que le principe de réalité
s'imposer eh bien là c'est le premier
nice la première ministre sait pas très
bien quelle formule faudra employer dans
ce futur mais on va faire la grimace moi
je dis la première ministre emmanuel
macron lui aussi me disant alors faisons
la législation macro est donc la
première ministre c'est elle même qui
d'une certaine manière ce arbitrera tout
seul en tout cas on pourra pousser dans
ce sens là donc et on la sait quand même
préoccupé sincèrement on part la
question écologique alors on va
s'intéresser maintenant au sort de
plusieurs partis politiques dans ces
élections législatives est d'abord un
parti qui part on va dire affaibli clr
les républicains son chef christian
jacob a déjà annoncé qu'il passera la
main après le 19 juin fabien becker qui
pour succéder à christian jacob à la
tête des républicains aux manettes
depuis et 2019 le député de seine et
marne cède sa place cet automne laissant
un parti marqué par la déroute de
valérie pécresse à la présidentielle
un parti qui doit se trouver un nouveau
chef et un nouvel élan aujourd'hui on
sait très bien qu'au sein du parti on a
besoin de tout refaire du sol au plafond
on a besoin de clarifier une politique
on a besoin de se réorganiser donc voilà
ces questions là doit être posée doit
être traitée et si elle n'est pas
traitée ça veut dire que c'est la vraie
question de la pérennité du parti prise
en étau entre la république en marche et
le r n ait l'air doit d'abord trancher
la question de l'orientation du parti
aujourd'hui notre responsabilité c'est
d'incarner une ligne claire libre à ce
que la dépendance et pour incarner cette
ligne à la tête du parti plusieurs noms
circulent dont celui d'eric ciotti
arrivé deuxième à la primaire de la
droite ou encore du patron de la région
auvergne rhône-alpes laurent wauquiez
également en lice le député du vaucluse
julien aubert qui s'est récemment
déclaré intéressé par la fonction reste
à savoir si ces candidats très marqué à
droite sauront rassembler toutes les
sensibilités
pour remettre l air en ordre de marche
pour être prêt il faut avoir un
responsable un leader du parti un leader
des républicains
suffisamment rassembleur à la fois pour
donner envie à nos électeurs pour donner
envie à nos militants de se battre pour
donner envie d'adhérer aux républicains
et pour dire oui les républicains c'est
la formation d'avenir et de l'alternance
de 2000 27 mai avant 2027 il y à la
bataille des législatives le score dlr
en juin prochain sera déterminant pour
l'avenir du parti notamment sur le plan
financier
joséphine star on sait on a un peu
l'impression de d'une équipe qui en sait
pas comment dire ça en pilote
automatique ou encore sonné par le
résultat de la présidentielle est très
peu audible il ya évidemment des prises
de paroles d'un certain nombre de
leaders depuis trois semaines mais très
peu audible quoi ça ça n'imprime plus
primés déjà pas beaucoup pendant la
campagne présidentielle
ils font face à plusieurs difficultés la
première date pas de la dernière
élection en date de 2017 c'est le
positionnement politique avec emmanuel
macron et le mouvement de la république
en marge qui est allé chercher plutôt
centre droit et impôts centre gauche
mais au départ c'était surtout le centre
droit est bien toute une partie de
l'électorat de l air a été attirée par
cette nouvelle formation politique et
les fuites ont continué la deuxième
difficulté c'est justement tout ces
déperditions d'élus qui passe
vers la majorité on va avoir pas mal de
circonscription en france avec des
candidats aient l'air face à d'anciens
élèves passaient la république en argent
il ya il ya tout un travail de refonte
interne pour les républicains mais
d'abord la question c'est avec qui
autour de qui avec quels élus ils auront
vraisemblablement toujours un groupe
politique au parlement c'était quand
même la première force de dons renseigne
le seuil sait combien ces trente groupes
politiques - lowe's cos 15 pouces et
gmail j'étais beaucoup trop gourmand
pour les financements il en faut encore
un peu plus le voile à avoir un parti un
peu sony c'est aussi ce que recherchent
les républicains c'est ce que
recherchent aussi les partis socialistes
et c'est pour ça qu'ils se sont agrégés
en tout cas une partie d'entre eux avec
l'union de la gauche donc ils soulignent
les deux sont quand même pas dans le
même flou idéologique il ya une place à
prendre mais laquelle et avec qui
mathieu moi je crois pas une seconde la
refonte des républicains
celle ouvert avec l'idée on va trancher
la ligne on va dans un grand congrès où
les grands débats ça marche pas comme ça
un parti ça se prend ça se conquiert sa
se détourne de sa ce pilote mais j'ai
pas de souvenir de partie qui aurait
fait son aggiornamento soissons un peu
passif y est responsable et qui aurait
donné une force une force combattante
derrière fois nos chefs et c'est un
problème de leadership il ya un problème
de ligne ça c'est évident et un problème
d'alliance c'est évident et un problème
de leadership c'est évident il ya
beaucoup de poèmes de stratégie tactique
des deux choses mais mais le leadership
d'une certaine façon créer le mouvement
jean garrigues dans les dents les
prétendants à la succession de christian
jacob évidemment le nom de laurent
wauquiez celui qui revient le plus alors
c'est un retour
au tour 2010 est en quelque sorte ça ça
pourrait être une solution parce
qu'effectivement la droite se
reconstruit toujours autour d'un leader
je dire que depuis de gaulle en passant
par jacques chirac et nicolas sarkozy
nicolas a pris le parti en nicolas
sarkozy a pris le parti en 2004 et c'est
arrivé après il n'aurait plus qu'en 2007
c'est quoi l'expression achève un chef
et un chef sachant chefferie
exercices de prononciation
et c'est vrai que en termes de stature
en termes de perception de l'opinion
publique laurent wauquiez il a peut-être
se se profile d'autant plus qu'il
incarne depuis quelques années quand
même une droite assez dur en tout cas
beaucoup plus dure que celle de valérie
pécresse par exemple qui pourrait
correspondre à cette aile ciotti de ceux
qui se sont finalement ceux qui ont été
en porte-à-faux par rapport à la
campagne de creusot qui ont mis valérie
pécresse en porte à faux c'est un
mystère cc républicain parce que
finalement ils ont ils ont quand même
préservé une centaine de députés en 2017
le leu leu leurs programmes sur le fond
n'est pas si éloigné que ça de ce que
fait manuel macron et ils ont ils ont
par rapport à l'opinion publique
française ils ont un certain nombre
d'arguments à faire valoir ils ont des
sénateurs enfin ils ont des
enracinements locale mais effectivement
il faut il faut on revient toujours à ça
à droite moi je crois pas non plus
l'aggiornamento idéologique parce que
leurs bases idéologiques finalement elle
est assez comment dire assez simple
c'est conserver protéger etc mais ces
leaders qui manquent mais un leader
capable est capable de fr le
rassemblement et puis ça c'est pas
évident et puis il ya quand même la
stratégie blockhead emmanuel macron
de d'assèchement par les idées et par
les personnalités il ya le sort de diane
de damien abad qui qui est le président
du groupe elle est aujourd'hui à
l'assemblée on vient pas de candidat
mais les wem en face de lui dans ses
législatives qui est sommé de clarifier
sa situation yves derai ça peut être une
des prix prise de guerre j'ai pas trop
le l'expression mais en tout cas une des
personnalités encore et l'air qu'on
pourrait retrouver au gouvernement et
donc la stratégie continuer et on voit
pas une force politique pour résister à
cette stratégie d'émana continue de
travailler comme 10 ou 11 aces a fait
vibrer mais c'est vrai que je ne partage
pas tout à fait enfin la vie de ski de
mathieu monsieur green qui attendait
dans un débat oui parce que j'ai senti
non quand même quand je vois les trois
candidats là qu'on a présenté huit que
l'algérie n'a mento idéologique se fait
pas de lui même c'est à dire que là on
voit bien qu'en fait on a trois
candidats qui pensent la même chose
julien aubert laurent wauquiez et le
troisième était mary siat eric ciotti
donc c'est la ligne la ligne nîmes à
dire que c'est à droite toute il y en a
certains qui sont même pour le droit du
sang enfin je veux dire c'est une très
très dur très très c plus que l'avenir
perd encore parce que ma perf finalement
nenê jamais jusque là donc je crois
quand même qu'il ya un changement de
ligne là il ya un constat qui est quand
même que les bertrand pécresse cetera
aujourd'hui je ne suis pas sûr qu'il y
ait un candidat solide qui puisse
chalenge et ses candidats là je pense
que le prochain patron de ce parti
mènera de cette mouvance là et après en
effet c'est vrai que ce parti de droite
qui s'appelle ump au rpr ne fonctionne
jamais aussi bien que quand il a assez
d'être présidentiable et donc pour ces
trois là le présidentiable c'est laurent
wauquiez et je pense quand même que
c'est celui qui est largement le mieux
placé peut-être run qui pliera le match
d'hier que s'il est candidat je pas sûr
que les autres il y avait contre lui je
voudrais terminer ce débat sur un fait
campagne qui qui qui aurait pu qui peut
sembler anodin mais quand même dans
cette campagne législative après le
retrait du candidat de l'année taha abou
hafs accusé de violences sexuelles un
autre parti était sur la sellette crm
avec le cas de jérôme peyrat maire de la
roque gageac il était investi en
dordogne jeudi cet anodin parce que
finalement elle a retiré sa candidature
cet après-midi et pourtant ce qui n'est
pas anodin ce sont les termes choisis
par le délégué général de la république
en marche ce matin il lui apportait
encore son soutien sur france info
écoute et il ya eu une affaire complexe
il n'a pas été condamné à l'inégibilité
et c'est d'ailleurs représenté dans sa
mairie où les gens le connaissent
extrêmement bien il a été réélu au
premier tour et se soumettra mais ça
fait pas au jugement des élections moi
j'ai pris du temps pour lire les
attendus pour comprendre pour savoir si
au fond on pouvait avoir affaire à
quelqu'un qui pouvait être capable de
violence volontaire je crois et je suis
mais même infiniment convaincu que ça
n'est pas le cas ça jamais j'aurais
permis cette investiture ce n'est pas le
cas ça donnait tonnes
c'était un honnête homme cette phrase là
elle passe pas vraiment en tout cas pour
moi quelques heures plus tard jérôme
peyrat annonce qu' il ne se fait il
retire sa candidature il était investi
au détriment d'une femme jacqueline
dubois député l'om sortante qui elle
avait décidé de se maintenir juste avant
l'annoncé quand je disais mais comment
joséphine savons comment ont-ils pu se
mettre dans un tel brouillon
probablement qu'il n'avait pas évalué là
on va dire la complexité de la sphère
juridique dans laquelle monsieur père a
été engagé mais ce qui est certain c'est
que ce n'est pas à monsieur guérini de
dire si
l'afer est importante ou non c'est à la
justice je la justice a donné j'ai
effectivement il n'y a pas eu
l'inéligibilité dont qu'il avait le
choix il a fait le choix probablement le
plus astucieux le plus judicieux de ne
pas se présenter et pour la république
en marche c'est un choix important
positif parce que effectivement qu'on
lui disait la journaliste qui
interviewait monsieur guérini ça ferait
un peu tâche c'était en train de devenir
une faute politique mathieu je suis bien
sûr alors pourquoi il était là parce que
c'était un projet aux maquereaux un
proche conseiller de wagons lits
la fonction du niveau et donc comme dans
ce parce que c'était la république en
marche pardon renaissance n'est pas
vraiment un parti où tout est quand même
très très verticale ben c'est un message
guérini a fait le bon soldat en
défendant en défendant jérôme peyrat ce
qui était indéfendable parce qu'on peut
pas placer son quinquennat sous le signe
de la lutte contre les violences faites
aux femmes et de l'égalité homme-femme
et défendre un cas pareil quelles que
soient les circonstances quand il ya
condamnation je vous rejoins les
condamnations pour violences
et de diriger les recommandations des
deux côtés ce qui franchement on excuse
rien et benatsou pas jérôme peyrat mais
c'était l'argument qu'il gagne à
développer donc vraiment en effet sur
l'escaut c'est étonnant parce qu'au fond
moi j'avais l'impression en voyant
stanislas guérini d'avoir un peu le
symétrique à ce qu'avait été l'attitude
de clémentine autain par rapport à la
sphère tard c'est à dire on voit là on
circulez ya rien à voir et puis après
bon quand l'opinion se se dévoile quand
l'opinion s'en plaindre s'empare de la
sphère bon ben là on laisse tomber là on
l'a obligé à abandonner sa candidature
je suppose mais la première tentation
c'est toujours toujours ça ça continue
pourtant classe politique est censé être
plus mature avoir évolué par rapport à
un regard de l'opinion et c'est toujours
d'essayer de mettre les affaires sous le
tapis en dernier quelque chose a changé
puisque avant la condamnation n'est pas
forcément une élection enfin gérald roux
pouvait se représenter en ayant été
condamné à de multiples reprises et y
compris pour des délits de la gestion de
du mandat aujourd'hui visiblement
l'opinion n'accepte plus accepte plus ce
genre de pedigree ou de genre de pièce
de casier judiciaire mais est ce que ça
peut être aussi
une première intervention de d'elisabeth
bornes peut-être que je fais de la
politique fiction à l'agencé mine sa
roue c'est pas la question la plus
facile que je vous propose mais c'est
pas facile et je n'en sais rien ce qui
est certain c'est qu'ils avaient deux
bornes dans son discours de nomination a
quand même rappelé que c'était une étape
importante elle était la deuxième femme
première ministre et que c'est un signe
envoyé à toutes les petites filles
toutes les femmes donc la question de la
place de la femme dans la société la
question de la parité est centrale pour
elle il est à mon sens évident qu'elle
ne pourrait pas cautionner que une telle
affaire vienne entacher la majorité
alors qu'elle est aujourd'hui la chef de
cette majorité d'une mère plus générale
il de vous lire vous ajouter quelque
chose juste une question elle est un peu
comme celle du poids fut toujours le
poids politique future d isabelle borne
et c'est vrai qu'il ya quelque chose
quand il faut mesurer c'est qu'elle est
la première ministre d'un président qui
ne peut pas se représenter qui ne se
représentera pas et donc le pouvoir
pourrait peut-être au cours du mandat se
déplacer à matignon il la question que
vous posiez au début d'émission qui
était mais pourquoi au fond elle va se
présenter pour être député elle est
peut-être là la clis terre que peut-être
que elle pense déjà au coup d'arrêt elle
fait la politique et veut l'onction
populaire elle pense peut-être à la
présidentielle parce que ma condition
représentera en 2020 je suis assez
d'accord avec vous on en est quand même
encore loin de la fin du mandat donc ça
plus le temps passera pour me veut
vous pensez un peu lourd ça c'est sûr on
peut avoir un coup d'avancé juste une re
dernier mot c'est en fait la première
première ministre de la france parce que
élite cresson elle était premier
ministre elle est lé premier ministre
ont pour
cela c'est ma sur rtl en juste après sa
nomination refusait de devenir première
ministre
c'est un signe aussi de l'évolution des
mentalités de faire la parité etc je
crois que le fait qu'elle ait souligné
cet aspect là c'est pas simplement de la
cosmétique c'est quelque chose qui lui
tient à coeur c'est certain maintenant à
dire qu'elle fera tout le quinquennat ça
j'y crois pas on sait qu'en général ce
qui est toujours un 1 12e suivre à
suivre ça fera partie d'autres thèmes
abordés dans cette émission et on en est
ravie merci beaucoup d'avoir participé à
ce débat joséphine ça on le rappelle le
titre de votre livre europe la
solidarité contre le naufrage qui est
donc publié aux éditions si nokia et
puis jean garrigues la tentation du
sauveur histoire d'une passion française
c'est publié chez payot merci encore à
tous les trois